josée legault michel david alec
castonguay bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir je
disais à tout début d'émission
j'utilisais je pense le mou sonné mais
en tout cas il était manifestement
encore un peu découragé du briefing
technique qu'il a reçu le premier
ministre goodyear de tous les tout ce
qui bouge en santé publique
il y ades pq je vous le fantôme puis je
vais vous entendre là dessus le 24 juin
ça demain la date où on peut espérer
commencer à penser à la normalité on a
deux gros mois devant nous je trouve ça
terrible de dire ce dont j'aimerais
mieux est en train de vous dire on a
quelques semaines s'il devant nous le
mont nord avec le va rien avec la
présence de lakovic et les gens plus
jeunes les hospitalisations
chez les plus jeunes on a deux gros mois
devant nous te dit qu'il nous reste
73 au 73 jours et après ça ça va être
l'été parce que at il expliqué on m'a
expliqué dit il que les jeunes on le
veut on le montre le tableau on le
reverra tout à l'heure sont davantage
hospitalisés davantage touchés josée
legault
on y voit plus par semaine moins une
fois par trimestre presque oui bon il
vaut par jour encore le premier ministre
a quand même donné un nombre de jours
c'est ça ma paraît risqué et parce qu'on
ne les barrières parce que la
vaccination le 24 juin serait peut-être
terminée mais seulement pour la première
dose
je ne sais pas si on réalise que les
gens qui vont avoir leur première dose
au mois de juin vont avoir leur deuxième
dose au mois d'octobre
donc on est quand même on parle de
l'automne et lorsque monsieur legault en
tout respect parle de l'été ce sera pas
le même été que l'été dernier l'été
dernier il n'y avait pas de varia et
l'été dernier on voyait pas justement là
tous ces jeunes qui arrivaient aux soins
intensifs donc je comprends que là ils
essaient de communiquer à la population
différemment
davant que ben on ne peut plus aller de
14 jours à 28 jours de défis en défi
mais commencer à penser à la normalité
le 24 juin je veux bien mais pour
qu'elle arrive ça risque d'être l'hôte
donc vous vous êtes fait encore plus
long mais déjà michel davidian cassure
avec la ça s'en vient la lumière est là
une semaine les deux trois prochaines
semaines michel seront déterminants de
l'aude ont dû maroc est ce correct là je
m'avoue j'avoue que je dois vous dire
clairement que sa voiture pendant
plusieurs semaines vous souvenez la
semaine dernière c'était avril qui
devait être le mois de tous les maux ce
qui sous-entendait qu'après ça on
commencerait à voir la lumière
mais là j'admets que le langage du
premier ministre c'est un peu déprimant
à le commencer à penser à espérer à
partir du 24 juin comme jaws et ça ça
risque de nous amener pas mal loin dans
l'été ça monsieur monsieur legault je
pense que la situation sanitaire est
compliqué mais là il doit voir que et
déjà avec les événements de la fin de
semaine
il peut mesurer commence à mesurer le
degré des carmes ans et ce dealer j'en
ai encore pour deux mois deux mois et
demi la à gérer là comment dire la
liqueur marylise attentes
oui mais voilà alors non aujourd'hui
c'est à pas une bonne journée on le
voyait dans le viseur du premier
ministre l'a signé
ils n'y étaient pas commenter ce pas qui
était fâché ce qui est un peu découragé
oui avec puis je vais loin de moi de les
tensions de faire depuis que j de
bottines mais j'avais l'impression
qu'ils avaient un côté qu'on a rarement
vu le découragement il s'est dit je
trouve pas une formule pour dire yéyé de
sa dictée là je suis sorti dépité de mon
briefing d'hyères est toujours des
journées plus difficile dans la vie de
premier ministre comme dans la nôtre
aujourd'hui c'était probablement
'l'annonce où on a effectivement des
mauvaises nouvelles pour encore un petit
moment et c'est tout à fait logique dans
la mesure où les variants se transmettre
beaucoup chez les jeunes et que cette
catégorie ne sera pas vaccinés avant
tard au printemps il n'y ni c'est un peu
inévitable qu'on soit pas capable de
donner plus d'oxygène avant la fin de
l'année scolaire ou du moins la mi juin
alors que contrairement à ce qu'on avait
déjà annoncé en février où on disait
quand les 65 ans et plus vont être
vaccinés vous allez voir la crise oui
différents près de 80 % des
hospitalisations cd + 65 ans ça va
permettre au réseau de la santé de
souffler on va pouvoir donner un peu de
liberté et là on voit bien que c'est pas
ce qui va se produire et je pense qu'on
a atteint la limite au gouvernement de
cette espèce de 2,2 volonté qu'on a deux
c'est toujours insuffler un peu
d'optimisme et d'espoir mais finalement
on soit pas capable véritablement de
livrer cette marchandise là en politique
on est mieux de baisser les attentes et
créer les bonnes surprises que de
toujours dire maintenant deux semaines
ça va aller mieux qu'en réalité c'est
pas vrai que ça va aller mieux dans deux
semaines on est mieux de dire on a
jusqu'au 24 juin puis si la vaccination
vaut bien le beau temps se met de la
partie les gens sont dehors les variants
sont moins efficaces avec la chaleur
comme ça a été le cas le printemps
dernier ben tant mieux on commencera à
annoncer des bonnes nouvelles au début
du mois de juin ou à la mi juin mais un
moment donné il ya une limite à dire
tout le temps à chaque deux semaines ça
va aller mieux puis finalement dans deux
semaines ça va pas si vite
ils sont finalement il a souligné josé
je jure un au tour de table il a
souligné qu' il y avait quand même
quelques mystères pour la suite des
choses il a parlé de la franqui l'italie
le brésil ontario il on sait on n'est
pas sûr que ça va aller aussi pire que
les que ça va s'enflammer comme on le
voit le constatent la bonne mais c'est
pas sûr que ça arrivera pas non plus
alors c'est là d'où le découragement
oui mais en même temps plusieurs experts
extérieurs à sa cellule de crise
on parle déjà depuis plusieurs semaines
et là on arrive à un autre problème qui
est qui qui est là depuis le début de la
crise
c'est à dire que la santé publique du
québec est toujours en retard par
rapport aux experts qui sont à
l'extérieur le gouvernement et cette
réalisation au delà de la part du
premier aspect c'est pourtant peau
malheureusement pour nous tous une très
grande surprise et je le répète l'année
dernière les variables étape alors et on
n'a pas le portrait qu'on a aujourd'hui
mais ça on le savait il ya plusieurs
semaines
alors ce que je pense aussi que
l'imposition très bon maladroite le du
masque à l'extérieur nous peut on pourra
peut-être revenir sur cet incident à
l'heure c'est un indice aussi que cet
été ne sera pas comme l'été dernier
parce que c'est quand même une mesure
majeure qui va être compliqué à faire
appliquer qui est nécessaire par contre
justement parce que la situation est
différente et ça a été présenté sa même
pas été présenté sa même pas été
expliquées et aujourd'hui horacio arruda
avait encore des difficultés à
l'expliqué lui même alors que quelqu'un
comme la docteur cécile trably expliqué
hier en une minute de manière
extrêmement claire pourquoi sauf si
cette mesure leur est important bon ben
focus on lance une seconde avec comment
vous avez compris cette drôle de façon à
effectivement d'expliquer cette mesure
d'abord n'a pas été expliquée d'une part
la semaine dernière
hélas aujourd'hui monsieur le gosse il
voulait parler de tout sauf de ça la
salle à gaza un peu comment vous avez vu
ça ouais on a d'ailleurs passé un peu
aussi par dessus le fait qu'on est
obligés maintenant au milieu de travail
dès que le 8 avril de porter un masque
en tout temps
on prête ses collègues ça aussi ça avait
été un peu évacués lors des différents
points de presse c'est sûr que beaucoup
de mesures qui sont annoncées dans
certains pour une presse peut moment
donné la litanie de mesures ou devient
un peu fatigante
peut-être qu'on aurait avantage à avoir
lorsque des grands coups de barre qui
sont donnés une séance d'information
technique avec la santé publique puisse
nous présenter voici pourquoi on fait
savoir si les tenants et aboutissants
oui on sait que des exceptions
évidemment ça peut pas être parfait mais
on se base sur télésud voici ce qui
s'est passé ailleurs ça m'a pas dit
qu'il faut absolument que toujours
séparés horacio arruda françois legault
moi je pense pas contrairement au parti
d'opposition que ça fait une grande
différence
mais nous avons un peu plus
d'informations techniques qu'il ne
forcerait pas le premier ministre a
passé les 25 premières minutes du point
de presse a expliqué ce qui est
différent et pourrait se concentrer sur
certains grands pins puis ensuite on
pourrait avoir un peu plus de détails ou
avant idéalement si je vais te reposes
bérubé est ce que vous dites là mais moi
je sais pas réparation arruda et
françois legault je crois que je me
sente ce ratio à roudet est emprisonné
du tout je pense que ça fait son affaire
qu'ils soient prêts des décideurs
ça lui donne une influence puis il
changerait pas sa position mais ce qu on
pourrait avoir plus souvent des séances
d'information technique on l'a on le
paye 10 gros projet de loi par exemple
des gros titres majeurs pourquoi on
pourrait pas l'avoir plus de la santé
publique qu'ailleurs le masque à
l'extérieur le masque dans les lieux de
travail quand on change le couvre-feu
d'heure explique un peu plus en détail
lors peut-être qu'on aurait moins
tendance à essayer toutes expliquées
dans un seul point de presse
welch elle devait donc communiquer
exhaustif avant par exemple ce qu'est ce
que bérubé avait proposé là oui tout à
fait je pense qu un communiqué.le à
partir du moment où ça devient tellement
compliqué l'eau t on à d'une jaune pâle
john moyennement pas moyennement foncé
puisse les règles sont différentes d'un
endroit à la presse d'un village à
l'autre on a vu qu'on est étendue des
zones qui étaient plus rouge du côté par
exemple de de choisir appalaches
mais moi j'aimerais bien qu'elle
de l'autorité sanitaire massue à riga et
monsieur legault soient séparés non
seulement l'occasion mais de façon
générale parce que j'ai souvent
l'impression que monsieur legault bon
mais parce l'apoc si vous me passez
l'expression à monsieur à rudolph quand
il sait pas trop quoi dire et je pense
que ça il forcerait à s'expliquer
davantage s'il n'y avait pas de secours
de monsieur arruda et inversement
monsieur al houda peut-être finirait par
avoir du temps pour s'expliquer plus
clairement parce que honnêtement c'est
pas d'aujourd'hui là que les
explications monsieur hulot sont
confuses - jose mais justement si
présent et c'est peut-être la raison
pour laquelle il ne les sépare pas non
je comprends davantage ensuite mais dans
la réalité des choses on a vu comme un
superbe doit par exemple à témoigner en
commission parlementaire l'automne
dernier sap a été sa peau bien aller
comme reprendre le slogan ça s'est pas
bien passé ses explications étaient
confuses
il se souvenait pas d'élément important
et cetera on avait l'impression d'une
certaine nonchalance alors c'est sûr que
quand il est avec le premier ministre le
premier ministre qui habituellement est
tassé le plus rigoureux possible dans
ses propres explications c'est m'étais
monsieur arruda tout seul et moi je vous
prédis que ça se passerait vraiment pas
très bien et l'a peut-être qu'on arrive
aux vrais problèmes aux os je vais oser
le dire mais est ce que monsieur harouna
est encore l'homme de la situation à la
santé publique je sais que le premier
ministre ne veut pas s'en départir bah
écoutez depuis l'an dernier la cia quand
même dans ma mesure dossier où la santé
publique courait après le virus plutôt
que le contraire
mais est-ce que alec il n'est pas
meilleur en privé qu'en public est ce
que enfin c'est la supposition qu'on
peut faire parce que si monsieur legault
et l'entourage monsieur le groupe tout
le monde le laisse là il doit avoir une
raison le nom oui ça faisait que je
pense que son expertise
elle est là il est appuyé par différents
experts avaient quand il a le temps de
s'expliquer de présenter c'est son point
de vue c'est peut-être plus convaincant
que lorsqu'il doit faire des phrases
plus ramassé plus imagé pour que les
gens comprennent exactement je trouve
que c'est quand même amélioré un peu le
récemment ont par rapport au début de
l'hiver où parfois on avait quatre
parenthèse dans la même phrase le peuple
garde ses réponses plus courtes ça aide
mais moi je suis moi c'est plus sur le
volet technique par exemple là on vient
de changer les choses en outaouais c'est
uniquement gatineau qui est sous les
mesures d'urgence toute la région de
l'outaouais
si on avait eu une séance d'information
technique avec la santé publique où les
gens puissent peuvent participer au
téléphone vous auriez nos collègues de
l'outaouais qu'avait posé des questions
précises
ça faisait quoi pour le pontiac comment
ça se fait que nos machines sont brisés
commencé que les délais sont longs il
n'y a pas d'accès pour ça et l'on veut
pas parler nécessairement juste de
l'outaouais dans un point de presse
3 c'est pas mal à ses parents band
trailer allez vous dire monsieur mais
d'abord la possibilité il ya plus de six
ans technique et michel david à la santé
publique
et séparer le politique donc de des
conseils et scientifique oui moi je
pense que ça serait la chose à faire
comme comme c'est le cas à tahoua là on
voit pas monsieur trudeau tout le temps
à côté de dr
madame tam donc monsieur d'hommes et un
des provinces dépendant de ce sport
souvent dans un roman ministériel
remplacer renvoyer quelqu'un c'est une
chose mais par qui le remplacer
et ça à ce stade si le jeu pas certain
que d'abord qui aurait tellement de
volontaires qui se porterait la
république mais écoutez c'est parce que
c'est pas une question d'être critique
c'est une question de droite et qu'il ya
eu aussi qu'il ya eu plusieurs ratés il
continua il y en avoir donc mais je sais
que politiquement le premier ministre ne
le propose c'est évident bon combien
nous leur rappellerons secondes
bon ça ok alors merci je voulais vous
demander est ce que l'adhésion vont pas
devenir un enjeu crucial on verra les
prochaines soirées
à 20 ans mais je vais vous rend
évidemment pour rien du type on en
reparlera merci à vous trois aura un
mois pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit